islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes
all of this and so much more can be on
your scale of good deeds click the link
and donate what you can
so my name is ali dawa
yeah
so i do discuss i'm a muslim
so i do different discussions with
different people variety of topics
what are you guys up to today
it's absolutely nothing
okay that's nice can i ask you guys a
question i know you've got to be honest
with me
as females walking down the road
do you get sexually harassed like cat
calling and stuff like that i don't let
it you don't get it no i don't like it
oh you don't like
anyone even if someone tried to just get
a bang in their face that's good that's
that's how you should be make sure you
go for the gin uppercut yeah uh the
thing is sister though what i was trying
to say is do you get catcalled let me
sexual harassment i don't mean being
touched
okay
now what do you think this stems from
like i know some people think that like
some people have this belief that i
think that we muslims think that
it's the way the woman dresses yeah i
don't necessarily believe that totally
yeah because there are girls who wear
the hijab that gets harassed as well so
it's not necessarily that i believe it
starts from top meaning women are
sexually objectified
and there is no respect and like we're
talking about the pornography industry
as well yeah and even when we're looking
at for example banners posters women are
always in a sexualized way i never see a
woman
dressed up let's say normally and she's
she's doing an ad about mathematics or
sometimes you go on safari and you want
to write like a school teacher they'll
always be like a weird sexual
outfit
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah glasses
because men think that women are objects
and they can use their look this
beautiful woman walking here with
dresses to have fun in a restaurant and
there will be a man coming on her
exactly
give me your number if you know she
doesn't give her number oh you're ugly
anyway yeah so disrespectful no not a
disrespectful sister that is absolutely
disgusting because we know how women are
insecure they decide to make them
insecure for you to go and call a woman
ugly you actually really because she's
not going to just ignore that she's
going to she's going to actually think
there's something wrong with me and this
is where it's really sad because it's
females what happens i feel like
sometimes i feel for you guys i'm a guy
yeah i feel for you guys because you are
coming across men who you don't know
what they want from you you cannot trust
them i came to islam nine years ago yeah
i was one of those men that i'm talking
about here and i hated myself and how i
was before because society society
society made me like that and i wanted
to rectify my ways and change my ways
you know why because i looked at women
as sexual objects but when i came to
islam islam humanized a woman to me
islam told me a woman has more to offer
than her beauty so as muslims i'm told
even if a girl is wearing a miniskirt
i have to lower my gaze god tells me in
the quran tell the believing men to
lower their gaze allah doesn't say lower
your gaze if you show in a hijab allah
says no there's a woman lower your keys
don't look why because we believe that
as i should teach my kids boys that you
know you know they have the concept we
used to have it back in the days oh and
she's acting like her excuse my language
she's acting like a whole tree
that's nonsense if a woman is not even
respecting herself you should have
respect for her i was coming back from
like a restaurant i was quite drunk you
know looking normal i was wearing just a
normal jacket normal jeans yeah and
these men started shoving money in my
face
like for sex and i got beaten up because
of them but yeah they really beat you up
yeah so just think how men are inside
their heads they're so insecure the
eagles are yes so high yes it's
disgusting that's why i do not know
because my boyfriend he's a muslim he's
a great guy
i trust him with everything you tell him
say a message from ali dawa
he has to marry you oh yeah no if he's
watching this let me tell you why yeah
sister to us a woman's security if i'm
interested in a woman i have to speak
let's say i'm getting to know her okay i
have to speak to her dad
because the reason i need to speak to a
dad is because if i have ill intentions
i don't want to speak to the dad yeah he
spoke to my dad already he has to speak
to him tell him i'm on his case now yeah
he has to speak to your dad number one
number two sister yeah
he needs to make sure you get guys get
married yeah number two you have a right
are you a muslim no no no okay we can
marry from the people of the book the
christians yeah okay
if i'm not mistaken you do have a right
to dowry yeah so um something that you
can ask for money god whatever it may be
yeah ask us whatever you like okay don't
be shy okay okay the reason we have this
in place sister is because so a man
cannot use and abuse a woman because if
i'm after the wrong things i don't want
to speak to your dad i don't want to
speak to you about the last people i
want to speak to number two like for
example my wife asked for a maha yeah i
can't give you the amount yeah it's
between me and her
she asked for an amount yeah that's her
right i had to give that now if i have
bad intentions i wouldn't want to pay
that much money
but it's yeah but it's her right and
islam tells me so right even when you
get married he has to provide for you
yeah he has to pay for the rent
he can't say to you go and work
because you can't pay the rent
yes
why not if you want to work that's your
money he can't touch your money
exactly but in a nutshell i believe do
you not think it's the society that
makes men like this why are they like
that
they don't listen they're not religious
for example throughout time as well like
ever since we like from a young age
everyone was just like oh if a girl does
this this or that yeah she's a hoe she
does this yeah when a guy does it
it's okay
if a guy fifteen girls always point
that's the thing that's what they say oh
body count they call this one background
when it's a guy the more the bigger yeah
now the thing is they're both wrong but
why is it for a guy it's a stage
they're trying to say he's a man
because these girls that you're sleeping
with you're actually destroying them
because they think it's cool to be in
the league no it's not it's not it's
it's wrong and you're psychologically
disturbing these women that's why
there's no woman walking these streets
that are broken because they don't know
how to trust they don't know how to love
because they've been broken and had
false promises so many times that's why
in islam it's so fundamental that when
you go about things the right way you
say look speak to my dad no bye-bye
simple as because when you do that trust
me if he really loves you he doesn't
mind speaking to your dad even if you
said i want 5 000 pounds as a dowry he
will you know why because i want to
spend the rest of my life with her why
wouldn't i and then not only that check
this out i don't want to hold you guys
longer yeah check this out in islam we
have something called willima so that
means when you get married you have to
announce it
not secret not oh this is my girl i'll
keep on the side no you have to announce
it to the community so people know so
it's to avoid these kind of things but i
don't know anything you would like to
say any last words
i just hope that men change over time
because the generations they just get
worse and worse and worse
i am hoping to god
more
men out there yeah because there is some
i i have the great one yeah yeah and i
just hope every single girl finds the
right one as well islam net is raising
funds to establish a masjid and
community center in norway every person
who prays there every kid that learns
about islam every youngster that on and
all of this and so much more can be on
your scale of good deeds click the link
and donate what you can